ed o'keefe as a reporter for The
Washington Post this morning we also
welcome him as a CBS News contributor
welcome sounds good when you say
everything does it yes my first question
really is it possible that they can fund
Democratic votes so that don't have to
go this way at this point it doesn't
look like it Charlie I'm and you have
the three moderates who over the weekend
said they're going to do this but last
night for example Jon Tester the
Democrat from Montana who's been facing
millions of dollars in TV ads in his own
home state said I can't vote for the guy
because he didn't answer question
sufficiently to me at this point the
math doesn't really seem to be there and
so Republicans are probably not to take
the next step and essentially move the
goalposts and so what does that mean
well only about four times in the last
50 years has a Supreme Court nominee
been filibustered requiring that they
exceed the 60-vote threshold it's a sort
of a tactic that's used to slow things
down and make sure that there's enough
consensus at this point looks like they
won't be able to do that the Republicans
so they can among themselves decide to
change the rules and just say way we do
this is a simple up-or-down majority
vote with 52 Republicans and the three
Democrats they can get them confirmed so
is it two wrongs don't make a right this
is what senator Heidi Heitkamp said over
the weekend as well a back from merrick
garland that's that's what many
Democrats have said yes that among other
things they're upset about the fact that
last year Republicans blocked him didn't
let him have a hearing never gave them a
vote because they believed that the next
president should be able to make the
pick and you know that strategy is going
to pay off probably by the end of the
week but it's inevitable that this is
going to happen what cards did the
Democrats really have to play the only
ones they can play is to do what they're
doing to slow things down to force
Republicans to make this decision and
make the change and they've been making
that point that you know the rules don't
have to change the president could come
up with a new nominee that's unlikely so
they're just kind of to change the rules
Donald Trump spent this weekend the way
he spends every weekend yep playing golf
but it was interesting who he played
golf with this weekend Senator Rand Paul
who left that outing from golf saying he
was optimistic about a repeal of
Obamacare has anything changed you know
I think the fact that they had the
meeting suggests that the White House is
certainly trying to make sure that
things change and Rand Paul is a pretty
good golfer I asked his office who won
and they refused to say you know what's
interesting about that too is it the
Republican criticized President Obama
for
too much go yep repeatedly yeah so we
stand there are Republicans on the golf
course now whether I suspect we might
because that may be one of the only ways
that he can only try to convince them
use the trappings of the office to help
get his agenda passed and Meryl hago is
really becoming something more than
simply a weekend place that's right
although this weekend they were at his
course out in loudoun county virginia
all he had to do was jump in the SI get
to go into his new jersey cool exactly
so i was just a cool yeah they got
plenty o what does it say about where
what is the state of the agenda on
Capitol Hill you cover Capitol Hill in
terms of Obamacare and tax reform well
they claim that they're starting to work
on it again on health care and in
essence they need to be able to do
something on health care to help pay for
the tax reform which is something
Republicans and Democrats are very well
they try to do them together we'll see
there are some suggestions you could do
that but they're there you know Congress
can't do big things these days so I
would be surprised that they did that
thank you and again welcome yes thank
you